il y à 25 millions de scouts dans le
monde 25 mille d'entre eux âgés de 11 à
15 ans sont rassemblés pour quelques
jours dans les yvelines près de paris
ils viennent de 26 pays il participe au
jamboree ces grands rassemblements
traditionnels et pendant ce séjour ils
sont citoyens d'une ville imaginaire
construite autour d'un thème
ce thème choisi ta vie ambiance avec
perrine ledent et marie pierre
cassignard d'accord ça ne se voit pas
mais cette course effrénée un seul
objectif récolter de l'argent type type
je vous rassure pour construire une
patinoire pour la ville de sponsoriser
parce que chez les scouts on s'amuse
mais surtout on apprend par m
il a un peu la merde et oui vu comme ça
ça paraît un peu conflit ici en fait il
faut aménager sa ville et pour ça il
faut accomplir des missions votre
feuille de route héroïquement à les
terminer
donc on va attendre 15h20 que toulon
sans revenu et on découvrira les petites
feuilles
ça respire la presse que de la bile
d'accord pour le scout citoyens le
chemin est semé d'embûches mais aux
valeureux rien à possible comme
remporter une campagne électorale
transforme en pugilat
le perdant tout comme en vrai celui qui
aura fait des promesses trop grande et
aux forçats confrères bon matelas et
seront au chômage y est oui mais gens
bourrés en zoulou cela veut dire
rassemblements et les jeunes sont donc
surtout là pour se rencontrer
évidemment parfois la communication est
un peu difficile
heureusement à part les problèmes de
langue
les échanges se font bel et bien comme
ici entre valenciennes et sarcelles et
les scouts eux font parfaitement compris
à quoi ça sert à nous connaître savoir
vivre malgré la fin nous connecte malgré
les régions décline ses parts en fait
voir de mirecourt fabrice beaucoup de
personnes
mais le jamboree c'est aussi la détente
il faut d'un cheveu bien sûr sinon ça ne
serait pas vraiment un scoop